Hello everyone,
this will be
the question
review for opioids.
So in this first question,
we have a 70 year
old female with
metastatic ovarian cancer
and she was started on
transdermal fentanyl
patch for pain
management, which of
the following
describes the receptor
pharmacology of this
drug. so we're dealing
here with of course
an opioid and we know
that with that
class of drug I did
mention that everything
is slowed the heart
rate the blood pressure
the GI motility
the eyes are going
to be pinpoint and
of course at worst
you're going to
have the respiratory
depression. So I
did say that would
be a way to identify
this group as
being G-inhibitory.
And G-inhibitory is
also going to be true
of the alpha 2
receptors something like
clonidine because it's
going to be affecting
sympathetic overdrive
in the presynaptic area.
And that would mean
that with clonidine,
you're getting
a reduction of
heart rate and blood
pressure as well.
GQ tends to be alpha
-1 histamine, the
muscarinic receptors.
and then later when we
do the serotonin 2a
drugs that too has a
gq mechanism g
stimulatory is going to be
the beta receptors
nuclear transcription
and you realize i'm
reviewing past pharmacology
is going to be
anything like the fat
soluble vitamins
hormones glucocorticoids
of course with the
hormones I'm thinking
about thyroid hormone
and the *** hormones
tyrosine kinase you'll
see a little bit
later that's going to
be insulin receptors
maybe growth factors
and then ligand
gated channel
incidentally we could
be talking a little
bit about ions. So
maybe we're talking
about the sodium
channel, potassium
channel. So in this
question, A is going
to be the best answer.
And going further
into its mechanism,
the opioids bind to
these receptors and the
alpha dissociates from
the beta and gamma
subunit. And next
you're going to have a
reduction of adenyl
cyclase, decreased cyclic
AMP, a decrease in
intracellular calcium
because there's a
closure of the calcium
channels which will
prevent calcium's entry.
On the flip side,
with potassium,
there's going to be an
opening of the
potassium channels and
that allows the
potassium now to exit,
as you can see
here. It's an efflux
and that refers to
hyperpolarization.
And that's going
to decrease all the
neurotransmitters that
are involved in pain,
like substance P
would be an example.
with pharmacokinetics
these drugs are
widely absorbed and
rapidly distributed
they're going to have
a high lipophilic
potential so they're
going to cross the blood
brain barrier and
they cause sedation
along with getting
through the placenta
they have a degree
of first pass effect
and that does change
of course if you're
giving this drug class
****** it's glucuronidated
and that's considered
to be a phase
two metabolism to
morphine six glucuronide
which is actually more
potent than morphine
and I explained since
these drugs go out
the kidney if you have
a degree of kidney
impairment you can
get more toxicity if
you build up the
morphine 6-glucuronide,
and that can create
sedation, and in worst
case scenario, the
respiratory depression.
And with normiparidine,
I explained that's
the metabolite of
meparidine, another strong
agonist, and that itself
is more excitatory.
It may increase the
risk of seizures.
A 50-year-old
homeless man was
brought to the
emergency department
having overdosed
on ******.
Which of the
following will
this patient
present with?
So this is now
looking at diagnosis.
And I explained that
everything would
be down. So, looking
at the choices,
diarrhea would imply
that there is increased
gut motility and
we know that in
reality, the opioids
do cause constipation
because they are
decreasing contractions.
So, I will say
that in this
case, this is incorrect.
mental alertness so
no if anything we
would be more in a
patient having sedation
he'd be unconscious
okay so this is a
no would he have a
low respiratory rate
i'm probably going
to agree with this.
Some patients have
a breaths per minute
being very low, even
up to or down to eight
breaths per minute.
So I'm going to
vote that this is
the best answer.
Tachycardia is a no.
If anything, we realize
that it's going to be
bradycardia because
these drugs will in fact
decrease the workload
of the heart and then
increase urination
given the fact that
these drugs do have a
constrictive effects
on sphincters including
the sphincter of odai
and the urinary sphincter
you will probably
get more of a urinary
retention so c would
be the best answer and
what drug should he be
administered for the
emergency so that's
going to be straight up
an opioid antagonist
like naloxone and i said
that naloxone works
quickly and that's a
good thing if we have
a patient that is in
respiratory depression
but it also has a rapid
offset which would mean
is that you have to
continue giving naloxone
until the opioid is
cleared from the body
because there have
been cases that patients
were given a shot and
within minutes they
go back into toxicity.
And that's another
reason why even
if the patient is
somewhere and is
having opioid toxicity,
you could give
it via nasal and
you are encouraged
to prevent that
patient from dying,
but you still have
to get them to the ED
to make sure that they
are, in fact being
taken care of that
that opioid is being
cleared okay so
that's a little bit
about that and i
mentioned these drugs can
relax smooth muscle
and i spoke about
papavirine being a
drug that does relax
smooth muscle and it
can be used before
we had like drugs
like viagra for those
patients that have
erectile dysfunction.
It's going to
decrease myocardial
oxygen demand and
the cardiac work.
And that's going
to also now lead to
a decrease in
preload, afterload,
and peripheral
vascular resistance.
So I did say that
there were times,
and there still
may be, that in
addition to giving
oxygen, aspirin,
nitrates,
there may be some
benefit in giving
morphine to somebody
that's having an MI
but it really depends
because we also want
to be mindful that
this patient does
not get some of the
adverse effects and
in worst case scenario
become addicted.
The respiratory
depression is really due
to the fact that
the medulla does not
sense the enhancement
of carbon dioxide and
that's where
patients get the the
respiratory depression
and then with respect
to the increased
intracranial pressure again
the vasodilation may
be attributing to
enhancing edema in
that area and that
can worsen the
intracranial pressure
especially in somebody
that has a head injury
the meiosis is
parasympathetic okay and
parasympathetic pinpoint
okay and that makes
sense for these drugs
and also drugs that we
use sometimes for glaucoma
that are considered
to be meiotic something
like pilocarpine
this is a muscarinic
agonist so understand that
when you have meiosis,
the eye can drain
itself basically a
fluid that's jacking up
the intraocular pressure
and that might be a
good thing if you have
somebody with glaucoma.
With medriasis, the
action is that it's
going to dilate the
pupil. We expect in a
sympathetic crisis,
whether it be ******* or
amphetamine overdose
that the patient would
have medriasis muscarinic
blockers since that
is turning on
sympathetics that too will
produce medriasis and
thinking about glaucoma
if the if the eye is
becoming dilated very
simply it's almost like
now it's becoming dilated
and it's not allowing
that fluid that i
just mentioned to drain
out so to speak and
that will increase the
pressure of the eye.
Meiosis is going to
be very important as a
diagnostic criteria
because persons coming
in with everything
being low and there is
meiosis, you have to
expect that this is
a likely opioid overdose.
And then tolerance
is not observed to
meiosis, which is
a good thing, and that
makes it an effective
way to diagnose
an overdose or in
constipation. A person
will be constipated
at the first dose or
even the last dose.
So trying to get
ahead and preventing
constipation is going
to be important,
especially if we're
talking about somebody
that is in later
stages like hospice
care or somebody
that just had surgery
because, you know,
being constipated
is going to contribute
more to pain.
So going off that,
we have a 67-year
-old male living at
home and he reported
severe pain due to
metastatic carcinoma
and was being treated
with transdermal
fentanyl. So he
was getting the
patch that we can
use for three days.
After the three
days, you take it off
and you put a patch
in another area.
And I mentioned,
by the way, if
the patient has
breakthrough pain,
you could give
something ******.
When considering
the specific
gastrointestinal
effects, which additional
medication should
be considered?
So looking at the
choices I have,
pretty much can
narrow down the fact
that A and D and E,
having mu receptor
agonist effects,
they were probably
going to create
more constipation.
So they're going
to decrease the
motility of
the gut and the
patient becomes
more constipated.
loperidine is
interesting because it
gives us a moment to
discuss that in the
event that the patient
has diarrhea they
can be given a mu
receptor agonist like
loperamide and that's
and that's going
to specifically work
now in preventing
those contractions
and what I would say
with loperamide, and
I did mention it,
is that we don't have
much of patients having
addiction liability
because this is the one
that doesn't cross the
blood-brain barrier,
unlike diphenoxalate.
But I did mention
if patients take it
upon themselves to
exceed the recommended
daily dose, there could
be a possibility and
there were some reports
of patients trying
to get a high off
that. So make sure
that we are very clear
with our patients that
they should not exceed
any medication without
getting some type
of guidance from
healthcare professionals.
And then Doc, you say
we don't know much about
laxatives and and how
they work but docusate
is considered to be
a stool softener it
almost works like a
surfactant and that would
make the stool easier
to pass if the patient
you know needed to
take um this dose of
fentanyl for metastatic
cancer pain so b is
in fact the the best
answer and again encourage
that the patient
can get fiber fluids
and exercise with respect
to the emesis just
to review that point
that might be due to
the fact that these drugs
can enhance or agonize
dopamine receptors
in the chemo trigger
zone with the sphincter
of odi I mentioned
if that should be
constricted, that's
responsible for moving bile
through the gallbladder
and pancreas. And if
that does not move
freely, there can
be patients that may
experience pain and pressure,
especially if they're
patients that have
gallbladder disease.
So, a 36-year-old
male IV ****** user
was brought to the
hospital with chills,
sweating, and
pyloerection. And remember,
that means that if
you look at their arm,
the hair of their
arm is standing up.
Sometimes they call it
a goose flesh. anyway
after stabilization
he was started on
methadone as part of a
detox program which of
the following is the
reason for the use
of this drug so
understand that couple of
things methadone
itself is considered to
be a strong agonist
of the mu receptor so
it does behave like
morphine and miperidine
and even ****** so
the answer here that
it's a partial mu
agonist is incorrect it's
actually a full is
it excreted faster
than ****** no it's
not okay there is a
specific reason? Is it
highly protein bound?
No, not really.
We're looking
for why it's used
for detox. And
as mentioned,
methadone is going
to follow the same
pattern of morphine,
but the idea with using
this in detox, it
has a long half-life.
So that's going to
prevent withdrawal
and really when we're
talking about why
patients ***** medication
it's not so much
for the high but it's
really for the low
because when you are
in withdrawal the
symptoms are horrible
so you are prone to
take more to feel
better so the idea here
is that you want to
give something and
I explained that when
we did the benzos.
Diazepam also has a
long half-life so that
too prevents the
withdrawal that somebody
would have say from
alcohol or maybe
a shorter benzodiazepine
like alprazolam.
So methadone has the
enhanced half-life
so it can do that
and then methadone
equal mechanism to
naloxone? No, naloxone
is for toxicity, is
for overdose, because
naloxone carries the
mechanism that this
is a blocker of the
opioid receptors.
So D, in fact,
is the best
answer for this question.
And the other thing
that can be used with
respect to withdrawal
that's getting
more popular is
buprenorphine because this
one is a partial
agonist number one so
it helps with again
the the withdrawal and
also some of the
cravings at higher doses
it behaves like a
a kappa antagonist.
It can be given
as suboxone,
which is known as
a formulation that
has buprenorphine and
naloxone on board.
And the other
thing that makes it
extremely special is
that it binds to the
mu receptor, but it
dissociates slowly.
And that is another
thing that would
make the drug persist
longer to prevent
now the withdrawal
symptoms, okay?
And then remember, also,
when you're thinking
about an overdose,
you have to watch
the airway. So there
may be situations where
the patient would
have to be ventilated
as well in the overdose
situation, okay?
Methadone also has NMDA
receptor blockade
for glutamate,
And it can also be
used, since it's a
full agonist, for
moderate to severe pain.
Not really as
much, because we
tend to use
this drug mainly
for the withdrawal
purposes,
but it can relieve pain.
And the other thing
which makes it a little
bit more concerning
than buprenorphine,
if you overdose on
methadone, you will
go into the respiratory
depression. The
fact that buprenorphine
is the partial
agonist, that makes
it a little bit less
able to cause the
respiratory depression.
But again, patients
can still take
either one and
end up in danger.
A 22-year-old female
was brought to the
ED with delirium
and episodes of
rigidity. On exam, her
heart rate was 190,
blood pressure was
70 over 90, 170
over 90, so it's
a high blood
pressure, and a
temperature of 104.
She was recently
treated with linezolid
for a VRE, urinary
infection, and
given some analgesic
for pain. Which
of the following
was she given that
may have induced
this presentation?
So,
linezolid is used
for vancomycin
-resistant enterococci.
That's one
of the drugs that
could be used.
It is a 50S protein
synthesis inhibitor.
and one of the
things that it can
do it does have
an effect on the
bone marrow but
it does have some
mal inhibition and I
explained that mal can
by its blockade
can raise certain
neurotransmitters so back
when we did
Parkinson's disease
the mal B increased
dopamine which would
be a good thing in
somebody with PD And
that's going to be true
of, say, pramipexol.
But linezolid
has more of the
MAU-A, which
means that you can
get some increase
in serotonin.
And that now makes
sense, because this
presentation of
delirium, episodes
of maybe being
rigid, and then
involuntary shakes and
the high autonomics
and the temperature
points to something
that we call
serotonin syndrome.
And serotonin syndrome,
I will explain
it a little bit
more when I do,
of course, the
antidepressants, because
they are a big culprit
of this, especially
the SSRIs and the
tricyclics. And also,
with the rigidity,
I'll explain the
difference between
between serotonin syndrome
and neuroleptic
malignant syndrome.
But for right now,
I want to look for
the drug that has
some serotonin action.
So buprenorphine is
not. If anything, this
is a partial mu agonist.
It has some kappa
receptor blockade.
and it also can
dissociate from the mu
receptor slowly. So this
is the one that we
give for withdrawal.
Mepiridine is considered
to be a strong
agonist. It has
anticholinergic effects. So I
did mention that in an
overdose of Mepiridine,
instead of having
bradycardia and meiosis,
it can be that the
anti-muscarinic actions
of medriasis and
tachycardia can prevail.
But aside from that,
meperidine does
have some serotonergic
potential.
So if you were
to give this with
linezolid, you
possibly can
enhance the
serotonin syndrome.
So B is likely the
best answer. The other
methyl naltrexone is
going to be the one that
is used for opioid
-induced constipation.
It has a quaternary
ammonium cation,
and being positively
charged, it
doesn't cross the
blood-brain barrier.
So you're not going to
get a high off that.
It's going to stay
in the periphery, and
it's going to have an
effect on the mu receptors
in the periphery,
specifically the gut.
Now, Trexone is another
opioid antagonist,
but we tend to use it
****** for those patients
that have alcohol
dependence because it's
going to stop now the
cravings because it's
decreasing dopamine
in the reward center.
Pentazocene is a partial
agonist or mixed,
and this one can
also have a, since
it's working more at
the kappa receptor,
there's less dependence,
but it also has this
effect on mood where
the patient can appear
to be somewhat
dissociative, delusional,
hallucinating. And then
remifentanil, alfentanil,
are sometimes used
adjunctively in
anesthesia in that they
would provide some degree
of sedation. They can
help the patient feel
less anxious due to
that sedatory effect.
And the other thing
is that they do,
if the patient is
having surgery, have
some effect at
promoting analgesia.
So B is the best
answer here. Okay,
and probably the
other thing that
I need to go
back is that the
normiparidine can
induce CNS stimulation.
Okay, so if your
body or mainly the
kidneys cannot clear
this metabolite,
you can get
exocitation. The patient
can present with more
of a neurological
effects that can
lead to seizures.
and these are the drugs
that are implemented
in serotonin syndrome
dextromethorphan
I'm going to
mention it because I
said it in this
lecture this is the one
that we buy over the
counter that will
have an effect on
the coughing reflex
in the medulla unlike
codeine it does not
cause the addiction
liability but again
if you take a whole
bottle of it which
people have tried to
do to get the high,
you could become
addicted over time.
And dextromethorphan,
in addition to having
that mu receptor agonist
potential, it also
has an effect at the
reuptake of serotonin.
So you can get
serotonin syndrome with
dextromethorphan
and say an SSRI. And
dextromethorphan too can
also have an NMDA receptor
blockade just like you
saw with methadone.
And the treatment for
serotonin syndrome,
you stop the
drug and then you
provide supportive
care. The patient might
be having these
movements which can
increase the
incidence of myoclonic
effects. So you give
the benzodiazepine.
ciproheptadine is
going to be the one
that is going to
block the serotonin
receptors and then
ventilation is of course
going to preserve
that patient's airway
so now this last question
we have a 42 year
old male presenting to
the ed with a painful
stab wound and he
was administered
pentazesine for the pain
after taking the drug he
experienced sweating,
restlessness, and an
increase in pain
sensation, which is the
most likely explanation
for these symptoms.
So given this presentation,
we are going to
probably say he's in
some type of withdrawal.
And the answer is,
you know, why? He was
given pentazocene. This
should work. so what
what's happening that
would cause him to have
withdrawal first we
have to think that
pentazocene is a partial
agonist and that's going
to play a role in
answering this question
so looking at the the
choices the patient is
allergic if the
patient was allergic he
probably would start to
get probably hives he
would his blood pressure
would probably go down
and he He would
probably, and this is the
worst case scenario,
he would go into
anaphylaxis. So this is
not an allergic reaction.
Is the patient
a ****** addict?
So again, this might
be the best answer,
but looking
forward, is it an
ineffective analgesic?
No, because it does
have some effects
on the mu receptor.
It is a partial
agonist, so it is
going to have a
degree of pain relief.
was he administered
this as an incorrect
dosage this is
probably, we have
no information on
that we assume that
he was given the
right dose because
he is getting some
type of response
and pentazesine
does not cross
the blood-brain
barrier, no
all of these drugs
have a degree of
lipophilicity so
they're going to cross
so looking at the
idea of the fact that
this is a partial
agonist well Heberwin is
a full agonist and what
could have happened
is since he's a
Heberwin addict and he's
given pentazocene
it being the partial
agonist and having in
itself opioid blockade
putting those two
together the blockade
would dominate and now
the patient is going
into withdrawal okay
so he's experiencing
withdrawal because
he has a full agonist
on board and now he's
been given a partial
agonist so now
instead of getting
efficacy you're going
to get the symptoms of
the withdrawal and
probably an aggravation
of the pain because
pentazocene is really
not working for what
you need it to work
for at this moment.
So B is going to be
the best answer for
this question. Okay.
And the other thing
to know is that even
though they have less
physical dependence
and respiratory
depression, given
their partial or mixed
agonist antagonist
action, um, you still
can get a patient
addicted to these
medications, okay?
So that's it for today.
If there are any
questions on this topic,
please let me know.
Until then, have a great
day, and I'll
see you soon.